يصبح الاغلب في تاريخ ريال مدريد برشلونه
يضع شعار روزاليا في كلاسيكو ابنه رونالدو
تتعلمان اللغه العربيه هذه الاخبار وغيرها
تتابعون على العربيه رياضه اهلا بكم
النجم البلجيكي اصبح رسميا اللاعب الاغلى
في تاريخ ريال مدريد وخان هازارد قد انتقل
الى نادي الاسباني مقابل 90 مليون يورو
عام 2019 وبعد مرور اربع سنوات وصلت
المتغيرات المدرجه في العقد الى 60 مليون
يورو بعد تتويجه مع الفريق بدوري ابطال
اوروبا ولقبين فليغا بالاضافه الى كاس
العالم للانديه
يستعد سبوتيفاي الراعي الرسمي لنادي
برشلونه لوضع شعار المغني الاسبانيه
روزاليا على قميص الفريق الفصلوني في
مباراه الكلاسيكو امام الغريم ريال مدريد
وكان البرسا قد لعب مباراه الذهاب في
الدوري وهو يرتدي شعار المغني الكندي تريك
وسيظهر شعار روزاليا على قميص الفريق كجزء
من اتفاقيه الرعايه بين سبوتيفاي ونادي
برشلونه
وبعد نحو شهرين من انتقال من العيش في
السعوديه نشرت اليوم جورجينا رودريغيز
خطيبه رونالدو فيديو لابنته نجم البرتغالي
ايفا والانانا عبر حسابها على انستغرام
اثناء غنائهما باللغه العربيه كما حاولت
الانا تسميتها ايام الاسبوع ايضا
[موسيقى]